good evening YouTube and patreon we are
this afternoon's entertainment and you
are beautiful hi it's me John wasn't a
great Joker impression because I'm not
tired enough to get that croaky tone in
my voice but hey there's a new his
evideo how joker should have ended which
hey that's a hotly debated topic already
or how it ended in the first place if
you're wondering why I'm alone Greg's
out of town with his girlfriend they're
having a trip they're getting a little
detox a break away from everything so
I'm here holding down the fort and
things are gonna change around here
alright first off we got a patreon
that's new q and A's TV show reaction
stream along some with highlights
footage included music video reactions
we're on the Stardust app where you can
check us out 30-second reactions any
film TV show trailer stuff we don't even
cover on here alright and we're gonna do
a reaction video what if we ever done
that blowing the doors open this videos
for adults over the age of 13 which is
awesome I love that this is such a legal
problem and it's called Kappa just takes
me back to the 1930s hey Kappa what do
you do whatever title those kids
[Music]
I did sort of welcome oh my god she's
clearly crazy and why we can't let that
kind of scandal I don't care if she's
lying or not that boy needs our help
Oh
he's dead no
[Music]
oh wow
[Laughter]
Oh buddy hahahaha so our parents weekend
and that's we bowed to Sharon and let's
crusade
[Music]
oh that was lovely
I like this a lot I mean like I always
enjoy these
Yeah right that was delightful always
appreciate a good hizzy I think I gotta
say I mean I always appreciate his e we
watch their videos periodically anyway
on this channel they're always clever
they're always fun they are always
amusing they're always some really great
sight gags and observations and
obviously when you're dealing with the
breath of different movies you even see
this kind of an honest trailers you know
some of them have more cheeky jokes as
they're leading flavor and some of them
have actually pretty sharp observations
and this one I thought hit a really nice
sweet spot between the two I know this
video is hilarious I really love the
characterizations they bring to these
first and foremost each one of these I
thought had a really nice observation
inside of the comedy because I mean the
stairwell sequences is on its way to
being iconic I thought that was really
funny though because I couldn't help but
think that a lot of the times I saw that
sequence in the trailer and even in the
movie I'm like it's surprisingly hard to
jump and dance on stairs especially when
they're slick like yeah I love these
sort of how did the chicken cross the
road
button on that the first one with the
kids stealing the sign I did think about
that during the movie and I mean that is
that sort of 1970s 80s wasteland New
York where it's just like nobody cares
about anybody and there's anarchy in the
street it's just a law it's wastelands
like Mad Max but if sand was garbage
instead you know like in the context of
the movie I got where it was going when
I kind of bought what was happening the
way they realized it at the same time
gives another thing where it could have
been just as likely that you know a few
people in the everybody might notice and
be like hey man we'll stop these kids
for you real quick and get your sign
back just like how peppy that scene
became like I think this is a video made
a really nice use out of the contrast
between how sad and dark The Joker movie
is with how bright I think they really
did the the I can't remember which side
at the moment I'm just gonna google it a
few moments later
so the Joker movie is the yin you know
the dark side I almost feel like they
made a lot of humor out of the yang of
this because it's a lot of like what if
the situation didn't go as she is
in the movie like what if every
situation Arthur landed it wasn't a
terrible situation
another thing with Gary like I didn't
even think about at the time I feel like
that's a pretty astute observation like
man Gary really could have like you
maybe he didn't cuz he was four it's
another one of those where like I could
see it going either way but at the same
time I'm like if all these circumstances
are going as poorly as possible man Gary
could have picked up the phone and
called the cops
at least clued them into something here
and then uh the one that I've seen some
comments here pointing it out it
definitely got me the most is just one
of the movie and it is so early on in a
past that we never got to see where the
Wayans actually do adopt him whether I
love that too it's like it uses the
movies ambiguity even the little Thomas
Wayne moment there your life is he
telling the truth and that I love Martha
is just like hey it doesn't matter who
this kid needs our help we have more
than the means to give it to him let's
let's give this get our help and you
know who Arthur gets to grow up having a
happy life be like a surrogate brother
uncle to this kid and it's funny because
it's so sweet he realizes his dreams and
it's like the good version it's like
what if Joker instead of a movie about a
guy being neglected all his life is
about a guy getting the help he needed
all of his life and then I love that in
the alleyway it crosses over to complete
absurdity to bring that into the hizzy
Canon with the whole wisecracker and the
batboy thing I thought was really
hilarious the whole thing with Superman
in this alternate universe really I
don't like this in here the whole I'm
pet boy just yeah it hit all those sweet
spots because you know what it is you
know that the funny thing is is that
because of the strange reality this
movie takes place in and the fact that
this is opening up comic book movies to
even more extrapolation than even more
what-if scenarios now I gotta want to
see the wisecracker bad boy you know I'd
watch like a half-hour cartoon about it
or something like that like if his he
made a wisecracker a batboy cartoon I
would watch that I just thought that was
really fun and an imaginative place to
take that that yeah brings it into their
world and then jumping over from the
riot sequence like okay but here's what
might have happened if the movie played
out completely as it did - that coda at
the hospital he wanders down the
alleyway past young Bruce Wayne which in
a weird
way I like this moment better than I
like to move movie not that this is in
any way plausible I like that
realization of the joke that the nurse
wouldn't get a little bit hurts if I'm
being honest and then yeah I having him
be in the villain bar you know really
tried to fit in with everybody and all
the 80s villains nitpicking the fact
that he is not a super villain so much
as he's just a trouble guy who snapped a
society kind of mired in the muck of
humanity rather than the lofty Universal
scenarios of superheroes and stuff I
like that they have via that meta
commentary like maybe this is one of
many forms you know talking about the
Joker you know maybe I'll live on
throughout the decades and you guys are
just gonna be relegated to the 80s and
anyway I'm rambling but hey this was
awesome
much love to the hizzy people go over to
their channel like this video subscribe
if you haven't and if you haven't what
are you doing with your life you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell get updated every time
a review or a video like this one is out
also check us out on patreon as well as
the Stardust app got a whole bunch of
fun extra content for you guys before we
end this off I'm gonna give a patron of
the day shout out to a very special
young man named Taylor Bentley Taylor
you're not pledged anymore I don't know
if you're even gonna see this I don't
know if you like us at all maybe I
offended you one day and I'm sorry about
that Taylor you're a nice guy you're a
nice guy but that doesn't cut but
seriously Taylor hope you're doing well
it's been a little while since we've
heard from you buddy and I just wanted
to wish you some love this Thanksgiving
week hope that you get to do something
nice and relaxing on the big day and
yeah just hope life's looking up and
when all else fails just remember to
smile though your heart is aching smile
even though it's breaking when there are
clouds in the sky you'll get by